rishi spent three-fourths of an hour for
two days working on his science project
kyle spent one-fourth of an hour for six
days working on his science project
who spent more time on his science
project
so we want to know who spent more time
and to do that we need to first know the
amount of time rishi and kyle each spent
on their science projects so let's start
let's start with rishi
and see what we know about rishi
rishi spent three-fourths of an hour
for two days so two times he spent three
fourths of an hour
or another way we could say this is he
spent three fourths of an hour once
plus on a second day he spent another
three-fourths of an hour
so three-fourths plus another
three-fourths will give us a total of
six fourths or six quarter hours
that rishi spent on his science project
now let's look at kyle
kyle spent a fourth of an hour so here's
kyle
kyle spent a fourth of an hour but he
did this for six days so six times he
spent a fourth of an hour
or we could say that kyle spent a fourth
of an hour one day
plus the fourth of an hour a second day
fourth of an hour third day
a fourth day
a fifth day and then a sixth day he
spent a fourth of an hour
so six times one two three four five six
he spent a quarter or a fourth of an
hour working on his project
so if we have
six one-fourths then we have a total
of six
fourths
so kyle spent six fourths or six quarter
hours
and now back to our question now that we
know how much each of them spent who
spent more time working on his science
project
rishi was six fourth hours or kyle with
six fourths hours and the answer here of
course is that these are
equal these are the same
rishi and kyle spent the same amount of
time so we can say the same
amount of time working on each of their
science projects